well levi man just won ten dollars on  this scratch off honey  quit pulling my dick  what come up in here lying to me  i ain't buying it you pulling my dick  first of all i ain't lying to you and  second of all  that's not the phrase come up in here  piss on my dick tell me it's raining  piss on my leg and tell me it's raining  all right now you wanna piss  and pull on my dick come on  do you understand you got all your  wrongs uh no actually  you got it wrong yeah  i yeah see you ain't even got a dick to  stand on it  okay okay let me ask you a question  what do you call those old plastic  building blocks what you mean dickos  name a famous comic strip detective leg  tracy what's with the  questions man do you know the name of a  giant cartoon rooster  foghorn dickhorn okay you done you done  give it that  all right yo you just got you got to  leave now huh  just cause i got a dick up on you  i'm elected to marijuana